Olá boa noite a todos é um prazer estar
novamente com vocês aqui apoiadores do
canal para mais uma sessão de perguntas
e respostas e depois a gente vai
discutir um artigo aí de interesse de
vocês a gente combinou da última vez que
a gente ia fazer invertido né primeiro
responder as dúvidas do do comento e
depois a gente iria para os artigos
então invertemos agora a ordem
bem eu vou apresentar a tela para
vocês me digam se tá fácil de ler
ou se vocês estão com dificuldade de de
fazer a
leitura aumentei bastante aqui a letra
qualquer coisa eu coloco só o texto e me
tiro da da
imagem primeira pergunta do
Fernando Doutor O senhor pretende
participar do Terceiro Congresso Mundial
médico pela a Vida Me inscrevi agora A
minha esposa tá me dando bronca e não
quer que eu vá lá porque ela acha que
todo mundo que comparece a esse tipo de
evento vai ficar marcado Eu já não penso
dessa maneira então acho que eu vou ter
que comprar aqui uma briga em casa para
poder ir caso positivo seguem algumas
perguntas para que o Senhor possa
filtrar e verificar a pertinência de
verificar no conteúdo da palestra ou
ainda de esclarecê-las junto aos
palestrantes tá então at essas perguntas
que ele colocou aqui eu gravei tá se eu
tiver oportunidade de fazer essas
perguntas não sei se terei eu as farei
Ok algumas perguntas aqui são bem
extensas a resposta né como como
proceder para evitar a vacinação contra
covid com vacinas né Isso aqui vai ser
complicado não vou falar mais nada não
que pode prejudicar esse vídeo depois né
Vocês sabem por quê
vamos partir pra próxima pergunta
aqui do Fernando Doutor já foram
mapeados todos os ciclos bioquímicos não
acredito que
não caso positivo Por que que as
recomendações de micronutrientes não são
feitas baseadas nas Reis necessidades do
corpo humano baseado nesses
ciclos
bem o que acontece é que essas
recomendações de
micronutrientes elas são baseadas em
estudos ou até mesmo
em opiniões aí de consensos nem sempre
são estudos mas tendo estudos eles são
estudos que avaliam as necessidades
nutricionais médias de uma população
saudável essas recomendações com muita
frequência não refletem as necessidades
individuais que podem variar devido a
vários fatores como idade sexo atividade
física e condições de
saúde então tem a complexidade da
variabilidade individual de uma pessoa
para outra isso não é levado em
consideração não é levado em
consideração que tem muita gente com
polimorfismos com mutações que tornam
elo mais vulneráveis e exigem doses mais
altas de
micronutrientes novamente os estudos que
estabelecem as IDR eles são baseados em
populações saudáveis não consideram as
necessidades particulares específicas de
indivíduos que tem problemas
aí e acho que muita coisa ainda precisa
ser descoberta em termos de ciclos
bioquímicos né não é uma coisa que tá
totalmente ainda
fechada é muito complexo a Biologia do
ser humano né de mamíferos em geral e
ainda não descobrimos tudo
Doutor o azul de metileno ingerido à
noite pode causar insônia eu nunca vi
esse efeito
Tá mas eu fui dar uma olhada sobre esse
assunto e vi o seguinte não é um efeito
colateral direto mas devemos considerar
que o uso de qualquer substância à noite
que possa causar um outro tipo de efeito
colateral que de alguma maneira possa
atrapalhar o sono e no caso azul de
metileno não é insônia diretamente que
ele causa mas ele pode causar tonturas
em alguns casos cefaleia
hiperhidrose isso pode afetar de forma
indireta a qualidade do sono eu nunca
tive hiperhidrose eu t azud metileno
praticamente todo dia cefaleia Pode ser
que de vez em quando eu tenha tido mas
para mim não tá claro que eu tive por
causa do azul metileno tá tonturas Com
certeza nunca
tive Lembrando que a metileno tem uma
ação antidepressiva
Então ele pode interagir com outros
antidepressivos e pode ser necessário
ajustar a dose baixar a dose desses
outros medicamentos por caus do uso do
AZ
metila Então faça uso doz metileno
sempre com acento médico uma pessoa que
já tem experiência com esse ativo
tá Marta perz acha necessário precaução
su de betaína base tremiti
glicina na suplementação com Sam Acho
interessante
sim porque o Sam é o s Adenil meina ele
naturalmente na maioria dos casos ele
baixa aína no
organismo porque ele é um doador direto
de
metil porém alguns casos pessoas que tem
algumas mutações específicas que tem
alguns problemas em algumas vias
bioquímicas específicas o Sam pode
excepcionalmente aumentar os níveis de
homocisteína
nesse caso a betaína base né
trimetilglicina Né o nome já diz
trimetil atua como doador de grupo
metil e
ajuda a a demais partes desse ciclo
funcionar melhor
E além disso a betaína base o trimiti
glicina tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias e antioxidantes porque
outro efeito que ele vai ter além de
doar metil é a do ar também a glicina
glicina é um dos aminoácidos essenciais
para formação
de então a suplementação com betaína é
uma estratégia muito interessante para
minimizar os efeitos potenciais em
algumas pessoas que pode acontecer pela
sua genética particular efeitos
colaterais possíveis com
Sam e sempre com acompanhamento com
médico né que entenda desse
assunto
certo vamos pra próxima
pergunta vocês estão conseguindo ler a
tela
pessoal Doutor Qual a sua opinião sobre
o consumo de cacau alcalino melhor
consumir Cacau 100% ou alcalino aí eu
acho que é uma questão de gosto pessoal
tá que que é o cacau alcalino é um
produto derivado das sementes do
cacaueiro obviamente né que passa por um
processo de
alcalinização esse processo reduz a
acidez do cacau para que que serve isso
para tornar ele mais solúvel em líquidos
e melhorar o sabor deixar um um sabor
mais suave mais adocicado
Até onde eu sei esse processo não
provoca nenhum problema no Cacau se você
souberem de alguma informação sobre esse
processo de alcalinização do cacau
causar problemas eu nunca li nada a
respeito então tanto o cacau comum
quanto alcalina vai ter antioxidantes
que ajuda a neutralizar os radicais
livres vão ajudar na saúde geral e
cardiovascular o cacau vai dar uma
estimulação leve através do seu teor de
teobromina que tem uma ação semelhante a
cafeína mas bem mais
leve o cacau alcalina é fonte de fibras
solúveis
pode ajudar na prevenção do diabetes e
no controle das gorduras do
sangue parece que o processo de
alcalinização do cacau perde um pouco de
nutrientes não é uma coisa que parece
ser significativa mas existe sim uma
perda de nutrientes então para você o
gosto do cacau que não é al canalino é
um gosto aceitável eu entre os dois
escolheria o cacau comum
100% mas se você acha que o sabor não é
suave você você use o cacau
alcalino Ou use os dois tá dependendo
numa situação você prefere usar o cacau
não alcalino e numa outra usar alcalino
como usar a zeólita para diminuir o pth
eu falei disso na Live anterior ele não
vai diminuir o pth de forma
direta certo o pth o paratormônio ele é
um hormônio importante no metabolismo do
cálcio se tiver alto demais pode levar
ao hiperparatiroidismo
algumas pessoas podem estar intoxicadas
com algumas substâncias tóxicas que vão
afetar a produção do pth então a zeita
indiretamente vai ajudar a regular o pth
ao adsorver que que adsorver não é
absorver
adsorver é que essa propriedade que tem
na zeólitas as moléculas de zeólitas
funcionam como se fosse um camburão e
funciona como se fosse um ã então elas
vão Deixando as substâncias ruins né as
toxinas na superfície
e desse então ele vai adsorver nesse
sentido é como se fosse um efeito de um
ã então novamente ele não tem uma ação
direta sobre o
pth ele vai adsorver toxinas E também o
excesso de
cálcio e isso pode ajudar a regular de
uma maneira indireta o
pth o jeito mais interessante você
regular o pth é através de uma dieta
equilibrada com cálcio magnésio vitamina
D K2
Ok e a dose da zeolita a dose da zeolita
é a dose padrão que eu já divulguei em
vários vídeos tá tá na internet tá no
meu canal Mas se vocês quiserem eu
coloco no grupo lá do
WhatsApp como é que eu
utilizo o
zeolita é uma dose padrão mas recomendo
que vocês façam isso com recomendação
Aliás não recomendação mas com
acompanhamento
médico tá eu coloquei aqui no grupo do
WhatsApp para quem quiser mais
detalhes próxima
pergunta
Inara vi no seu canal a respeito do
cominho Preto comprei quero fazer o óleo
de cominho preto como utilizá-lo tá
vamos dar umas instruções para
você então o cominho preto também
conhecido como nigela aativa é um
produto anti-inflamatório muito
interessante para quem tem rach moto ele
ajuda a combater a tiroid ashimoto tem
conhecidas propriedades medicinais e
cosméticas rico em antioxidantes ácidos
grassos e vitaminas e para fazer o óleo
de cominho Preto Você vai precisar
Sementes da planta eh óleo vegetal
também que eu recomendo que seja óleo de
coco óleo de oliva então vai pegar 100 g
de sementes de cominho Preto 500 ml de
óleo vegetal vai colocar as sementes do
cominho Preto num frasco de vidro cobrir
com óleo deixar o frasco em um local
fresco escuro por cerca de duas a três
semanas né esse material misturado
agitando o frasco todos os dias para
misturar e depois desse período de duas
três semanas você vai fazer a filtragem
você vai coar o óleo com um filtro de
café ou uma gase para remover as
sementes e armazenar Esse óleo em um
frasco de vidro escuro mantendo em local
fresco Então esse óleo de cominho preto
pode ser utilizado de várias formas você
pode aplicar sobre a pele algumas
gotinhas para hidratar reduz inflamação
uma pele irritada combater acne também
você pode colocar no cabelo no couro
cabeludo para estimular o crescimento do
cabelo reduzir a queda e tomar também
uma colher de sopa de óleo por dia para
aproveitar os benefícios antioxidantes e
anti-inflamatórios
certo vamos paraa próxima pergunta ho já
eu tô aqui meio mal posicionado deixa eu
melhorar minha posição aqui que eu tô no
meu quarto hoje não estou na no
escritório porque o escritório foi
sequestrado aí pela pela a minha filha
que está fazendo aula aula de inglês
online vamos lá próxima
pergunta Eliane idos 82 anos
shbg
testerona acima do valor de referência
pode estar relacionado com Ferritina
ferro e saturação de transferrina só uma
pergunta complexa né E na verdade tá bem
no limite do que eu falo para
vocês não me mandarem casos específicos
Tá eu vou responder essa daqui porque
ainda considero quea tá um
pouquinho impessoal Certo e pode ajudar
outras pessoas também então existe uma
relação entre esse hbg que é a globulina
de ligação a testosterona ou a globulina
de ligação a hormônios sexuais em geral
também a própria testosterona
Ferritina o ferro e a saturação de
transferina porém ela é complexa essa
ligação pode ser influenciada por vários
fatores especialmente pessoas de mais
idade então uma pessoa de 82 anos um
homem com shbg e testosteron acima do
valor de
referência pode ter também níveis Altos
de ferritina ferro e saturação de
transferrina
nós sabemos que shbg é uma proteína que
liga e transporta os hormônios
sexuais incluindo a própria testosterona
e níveis elevados de shbg podem segurar
a testosterona e não deixá-la agir Mas
pode também tá associada a várias outras
situações como doenças hepáticas uso de
alguns medicamentos e outras alterações
hormonais e a Ferritina é uma proteína
que armazena ferro no
corpo níveis elevados de ferritina
geralmente é
Mação ou sobrecarga de ferro ou as duas
coisas
juntas existe uma doença chamada
hemocromatose que é genético que também
leva o acúmulo de
ferritina a saturação de transferina é
uma medida de tão de quão cheio está a
proteína transferrina de Ferro então
níveis elevados da saturação de
transferrina também pode indicar
sobrecarga de Ferro então a relação
entre dois parâmetros pode ser
influenciada por fatores por umidade
sexo condições de saúde que estejam por
trás e uso
medicamentos então a sobrecarga de ferro
pode causar sintomas como fadiga dor
articular infamação crônica além de
problema de pele em casos graves pode
ter dar dano no fígado como é o caso do
da
hemocromatose também pode causar danos
coração e outros órgãos
níveis elevados de shbg e testosteron
pode estar relacionados a sintomas como
acne P de cabelo alterações de humor e
problemas de sono então o tratamento
depende da causa então se a pessoa tiver
com a dieta com excesso de Ferro você
tem que mudar a alimentação Às vezes tem
que fazer a quelação do ferro com
substâncias
específicas muitas vezes tem que fazer a
flebotomia né o sangria para reduzir os
níveis de ferro no
sangue e tratar os desequilíbrios
hormonais e tratar o fígado também se a
pessoa tiver com problema no
fígado certo então falando de modo geral
essas coisas que ela comentou aqui podem
estar relacionadas mas tratamento
adequado tem que ser feito com o médico
no consultório não dá para fazer esse
tratamento por conta
própria bem
próxima pergunta do Eliseu recentemente
duas biomédicas Me disseram que a
vitamina C corta o efeito da ozon
terapia se ingerir no mesmo dia da
sessão Então essa obsessão Eliseu com
essa questão da ozonioterapia o que que
corta o que não corta eu acho isso muito
pouco relevante já que a dose de
vitamina C que você vai tomar vior
dificilmente vai ter esse efeito tão
relevante no ozônio tá Teoricamente sim
porque a vitamina C
antioxidante e O ozônio é pro oxidante
então Teoricamente você deveria fazer o
ozônio e no dia seguinte a vitamina C na
prática Eu acho que isso é muito pouco
relevante muito pouco relevante porque
você vai tomar vitamina C horas antes do
ozônio e provavelmente essa vitamina C
vai ter saído do seu organismo no
momento que você tá fazendo a sessão
porque a vitamina C tem uma vida muito
curta no organismo A não ser que você
entupa de vitamina C meio que de
propósito no dia do ozônio que eu acho
que é muito improvável que você vai
fazer
isso agora tem um bom motivo para usar
vitamina C no dia do ozônio use não tem
um bom motivo não use é simples assim
né então se você puder evitar Evite o
consumo da vitamina C no dia do ozônio
faz no dia seguinte porque aí você vai
tá ajudando o organismo a se recuperar
do efeito pro oxidante do
ozônio mas isso que na prática isso aqui
não é relevante viu Eliseu você tá um
pouco obsecado com essa história do
ozônio aí eu te falei você tá buscando
muito pelo em ovo Eliseu tem que ser um
pouquinho mais objetivo e prático nos
seus questionamentos tá você ve às vezes
faz umas perguntas assim e se eu tiver
resfriado num dia que eu avião tiver
passando pela minha casa e esse avião
for da Gol e tiver chovendo
E também o cachorro tiver latindo na
esquina Será que acontece isso aquilo
outro entendeu el eu tem tem assim tem
que ter um pouquinho de eh bom senso
umas coisas que não são relevantes no
dia a dia não entenda isso como uma
crítica ruim é só tô te dando um um
toque para você ter um pouquinho mais de
Senso prático nas perguntas né no dia a
dia de modo geral
né eh nesse vídeo alguns segundos o
psiquiatra integrativo Dr Pedro neuro
phd em Harvard menciona alguns artigos
científicos para afirmar que mesmo o
celular desligado também atrapalha o Son
sim eu concordo com isso você confirma
as as informações
confirmo por que que o celular desligado
atrapalha o sono porque mesmo desligado
o celular tá recebendo radiação
eletromagnética el Pode emitir radiação
eletromagnética né tem aparelho como o
caso da Apple acho que é pior isso no
iPhone do que no Android que ele tá o
tempo todo ligado você pode se desligar
ele praticamente você teria que tirar a
bateria né que no caso desse aparelho
não é
possível Lembrando que essas informações
sobre os danos das radiações
eletromagnéticas ainda é discutível na
literatura mas tem estudos sim que
indicam que mesmo quando o celular está
desligado ele poderia interferir no sono
devido à poluição eletromagnética então
eu recomendo deixar o celular fora do
quarto ou se não for possível deixar ele
mais longe do seu
corpo vamos pra próxima
pergunta na Live passada você disse que
o corante das cfas pode gerar problemas
e que você costuma solicitar para
farmácia manipulação sem corante Sim
Isso significa que os suplementos de
marcas famosas tais como n Foods Dr best
Life extens são muito perigosos não eu
não falei que corante é muito perigoso
falei que eu eu atendo pacientes
sensíveis e para evitar problemas eu
peço pra farmácia fazer sem esses
corantes que em pessoas sensíveis vai
ser um
problema agora quando você for ingerir
um produto dessas empresas aí que tem
corantes uma ferida com fabricante
porque esse corante pode ser sintético
ou natural os corantes sintéticos como é
os casos dos derivados de petróleo podem
causar reações adversas como eu falei
especialmente pessoas sensíveis
os naturais que é o caso da Clorofila do
ucum eles são geralmente Seguros A não
ser que a pessoa tenha alergia né Então
essas marcas famosas que você mencionou
nowfoods Doctor best
etc tem que perguntar pros fabricantes
verificar com os fabricantes se esses
corantes são sintéticos ou
naturais
Ok
eh num vídeo recente você disse que ao
tomar suplemento pqq é preferível pqq
extraído de bactérias fermentadas ao
invés de sintéticas Como reconhecer no
pote suplemento pqq que é extraído de
bactérias fermentadas O que é que vem
escrito na etiqueta
então dá uma
procurada você tem que buscar a seguinte
informação procure na embalagem frases
como origem
vegetal ou produzido por fermentação
bacteriana isso indica que esse pqq
partir de bactérias
fermentadas se você também puder busque
lá se tem especificado a bactéria
então tem
algumas empresas aluns fabricantes que
colocam especificamente a
bactéria então eu tô aqui procurando mas
existe alguns fabricantes que colocam
por
exemplo especificamente a bactéria
hipic
denitrificans c 2
tá então alguns fabricantes Vão colocar
essa
informação verifique também o grau de
pureza do produto um pqq de alta
qualidade deve ter uma pureza
99% isso vai tá na etiqueta também e
certificações como é o caso gmo
Project que garante que o produto não
contém organismo geneticamente
modificados Ok então essas informações
você vai buscar no rótulo
na Live passada você disse que tem quase
certeza que o ovo caipira vermelho tem
mais luteína que o caipira branco que
você teria que dar uma checada sim eu
dei a
checada e sim os ovos caipiras TM mais
luteína do que os ovos caipiras desculpa
do que os ovos não caipiras tá
especialmente os ovos caipiras vermelhos
então se a casca do ovo for mais escura
é um sinal que tem mais luteína
tá então o ovo caipira tem mais luteína
que o ovo de granja e o caipira vermelho
tem mais luteína que o caipira Branco ok
tá confirmada essa
informação e além da luteína esses ovos
caipiras mais escuros são ricos em
colina que é muito importante na parede
das células né dos neurônios
especialmente também paraa saúde do
fígado e na prevenção de doenças
degenerativas então Além disso mais
importante que a cor da casca é a cor da
Gema Quanto mais a gema for escura né
mais vai ter nutrientes nesse nesse ovo
aqui tem da Maria Helena Por que que é
tão famoso tão caro o magnésio treonato
se ele absorve tão pouco 8% e é você é
segura a tabela
baixo então é porque você tá confundindo
absorção com o percentual de magnésio é
porque é o seguinte esse é que dá Muita
confusão mesmo e a molécula do treonato
é uma molécula muito
grande então pelo fato essa molécula
grande
eh para cada 10 mg como você colocou
aqui de treonato você vai ter menos do
magnésio elementar E como é que você faz
isso você tem que compensar você tem que
aumentar o volume de magnésio treonato
Isso é um problema porquee é mais caro
então não é a absorção é o percentual
que tem de magnésio elementar em cada
forma de magnésio quelado quanto menor a
molécula mais você vai ter
percentualmente
a quantidade de magnésio Ok então você
entendeu o que eu expliquei não sei se
você tá ao vivo Maria Helena mas e não é
absorção isso aqui isso aqui é o
percentual de magnésio elementar que tem
dentro da molécula Ficou claro para você
isso não sei se você tá ao vivo Deixa eu
ver aqui
me parece que não você vai ter que ver
depois gravado
né bem vamos continuar
aqui aprendi que devo tomar zeol em
jejum sim tem que ser em jejum posso
tomar com T3 T4 Não de jeito nenhum você
tome longe do T3 T4 senão você vai
prejudicar absorção Então você tome o T3
T4 em jejum e deixa para tomar Ó tem
outro horário tá pode ser no meio da
manhã no meio da tarde ou antes de
dormir mas não tome junto com T3 T4 você
vai deixar ele bloquear absorção T3 T4
Eliseu perguntei sobre vitamina C e
ozônio porque costumo comer alimentos
que tem vitamina C sim mas isso não é
relevante Eliseu não é entendeu menos
relevante ainda que se você tivesse
fazendo
suplementação daí Imaginei a
possibilidade dess meso atrapalhar o
efeito Não vai atrapalhar o efeito da
ozone terapia entendeu é a mesma coisa
você fala assim ficou famoso a
informação de que todos os antioxidantes
que você vai tomar antes de uma malhação
vão atrapalhar a hipertrofia agora você
vai deixar de comer então porque tem
vitamina C nos alimentos que vai
atrapalhar a hipertrofia porque vai ter
efeito antioxidante antiinflamatório e
vai atrapalhar a inflamação necessária
paraa hipertrofia não faz sentido né
entende Qual é a correlação de uma coisa
com a outra
então Desencana disso Eliseu tá vamos
ver as perguntas ao
vivo tá fácil de ler obrigado a
informação do Eliseu aqui as no
comecinho da Live
eh Fernando castelane excelente Obrigado
Doutor sei que não que são perguntas de
respostas extensas e com tópicos
sensíveis sim eu vou tentar pegar
essas respostas que você falou não não
vou garantir tá nem sei se eu vou porque
a minha esposa não quer que eu vá
eh quem tem perna de cowboy devido ao
joelho varo terá problemas na perna se
não fizermos colação vai ter problema
sim
e dependendo do grau de de curvamento né
vai ter problema sim problemas geral não
só musculação mas em alguns casos
também antes de fazer zapia
tem que fazer Quais exames primeiro
exames de rotina e mais a g6pd a glicos
se fosfato desidrogenase g6pd que essa é
uma enzima importante para pessoa poder
responder de maneira adequada a terapias
oxidativas Esse aí que você acabou de
colocar
aí obrigado pelas palavras boa noite
hipotiroidismo pode provocar Psicose não
eu saiba não hipertiroidismo em algumas
circunstâncias
sim Psicose tem cura se for um estado de
delírium delírium não é Delírio delírium
por conta de uma situação
orgânica tem cura agora Psicose que
pessoal geralmente usa no dia a dia a
palavra é qu que não é considerada como
curável
de nada
Inara
Amei que não está na sua sala por dar
Eco para mim na TV Ah é Então tá bom que
bom que você
gostou mas da eco em qual sala a sala
que eu tô no consultório hoje que tá de
mudança tem menos coisa lá e tá dando
Eco ou a sala aqui do Home Office que
vocês vê atrás ass ser uma bancada
marrom dá para explicar para mim qual
que a sala que tá te dando
Eco boa noite boa noite a TAM miquinha
sobre magnésio sim não entendi o
contexto miquinha tem uma pergunta de
Cristian nosso grupo que não está
conseguindo entrar a vitamina B12 em
crianças de 5 anos 560 é normal sim é
normal soua Maria Helena
Ah sim TAM miquinha Então você entendeu
né a minha explicação sobre o
magnésio treonato e os outros magnesios
quelados né de moléculas retirar da
vesícula diminui o poder de decisão
Eliseu não tenho
certeza não tenho certeza
o ideal seria inere zolita quanto tempo
mais ingestão T3 T4 pelo menos uma hora
depois
tá excesso de ferro pode provocar pedra
na
vesícula hum depende alguns casos sim em
alguns casos sim é mais comum quem tem
anemia que não seria excesso de ferro
mas seria excesso de
hemólise pessoas tem anemia falsiforme
às vezes faz hemólise E aí libera mais
ferro mais
bilirrubina e causa um aumento de
distante de pedra na visícula
a principal causa psicológica da
retirada de vesícula é excesso de raiva
acumulada el dizu essas coisas aí que
você tá vendo eu não posso confirmar tá
eu nunca li a respeito disso a Live
passada você disse que 0,5 de melatonina
não é o suficiente para atuar como
antioxidante para o objetivo como
antioxidante poderoso
inclusive para câncer não a partir de
qual quantidade para câncer seria uns 10
mg para cima mas só para câncer
tá Quando se diz que a minha vida de um
suplemento possui 5
horas isso significa metade do tempo
dele que ele vai ficar fazendo efeito
não é a metade do tempo que ele foi na
verdade é o tempo em que metade da
substância foi metabolizado pelo
organismo tá então é o tempo em que
metade da substância foi metabolizada
pelo organismo esse que é o conceito de
minha
vida
eh a sala que sempre faz Live deve ser
aqui de casa mesmo né Deve ser aqui de
casa porque a Geralmente eu faço a
maioria das lives aqui em casa eu te
pergunto se no fundo não tem se você não
vê no fundo uma
bancada marrom porque quando eu faço a
Live lá da Clínica o fundo é a janela a
janela que tem uma persiana então de
repente você lembra se o fundo é
persiana ou se o fundo era uma uma sala
mais comprida com móvel no fundo lá
Marrom Você publicou no seu telegram uma
foto dos produtos Cora Brasil e hora e
hora não é Cora não e hora parece ser
mesmo né mas é eora com mensagem que são
produtos 100% naturais sabe me dizer se
existem 100 prod 100% naturais para
alisamento de cabelo para alisamento
acho que não e tem corantes né para
cabelo tem tinturas que eu falei em
vídeo no
YouTube por qual motivo os laboratórios
orientam dizendo que é importante que a
coleta seja feita até 2 horas após o
horário que você costuma
acordar até 2
horas talvez é relacionado ao cortisol
eu não sei bem porque que eles falam
isso não Eliseu
chocolate 100% Cacau e orgânico é
totalmente isento de toxinas Depende se
o se o cacau foi plantado num terreno
que tem toxinas mesmo sendo orgânico ele
pode ter toxinas né porque no orgânico
significa não tem defensiva agrícola mas
às vezes de o azar de plantar num num
terreno que tem outro tipo de
contaminação injeção de Gava com
magnésio tira ansiedade em poucos
minutos sim se for feito
intramuscular Você pode ter esse efeito
sim quem tem pé na vesícula tem como
evitar a cirurgia sim não é obrigatório
100% das vezes operar não se a pessoa
for totalmente assintomática por muitos
anos com a pedra eu sugiro não operar tá
é caso a caso que ser visto né mas isso
que eu acabei de falar Pode valer para
várias pessoas
se a pessoa nunca consumir carboidrato
nenhum nem mesmo carboidrato residual
ela morre Como assim residual residual
do quê é impossível não comer nenhum
carboidrato Eliseu é impossível até na
carne vai ter um pouquinho se a pessoa
só comer carne o dia inteiro vai ter né
e é muito improvável que ela vai fazer
isso provavelmente ela vai comer alguma
salada algum legume e vai ter
carboidrato supositório
orgânico funciona
funciona para quem não tolera nem mesmo
resquício de lactose casina pode tomar o
prein só se for o Protein Isolado mesmo
assim com muita cautela aí nesse caso
vale a pena mais é usar o mixite ou
outro tipo de
aminoácido essencial né bem vamos pro
artigo não le Eliseu não vai deixar ter
artigo hoje ó lá ômega3 impede que as
gorduras ingeridas se convertam em ôa
Não eu não entendi direito essa pergunta
mas não omega3 não vai
impedir na verdade não vai ter essa
conversão você vai ingerir ômega-6 você
vai ingerir gordura saturada e vai
ingerir ômega3 ômega-9 essa conversão é
muito é muito pequena no organismo
existe sim a possibilidade de
converter parte do ômega-6 e ômega-3 mas
as enzimas são pouco ativas agora o
contrário
que eu saiba também não acontece com
frequência
não quem faz uso de Utrogestan não é
necessário utilizar gaba pois os
receptores são os
mesmos mais ou menos a progesterona oral
ela é parcialmente convertida em alo
pregnenolona que estimula o receptor
gaba
Tá mas vai depender muito de pessoa para
pessoa Geralmente quem toma progesterona
oral e fica tranquilo ela dorme bem e
não precisa usar gaba associado né
porque já tá estimulando o receptor gaba
Mas isso é variável de pessoa para
pessoa faltou responder a pergunta de
Mira e Nara Que pergunta de Mira e Nara
eu não sei então Repete a pergunta por
favor essa
aqui quando fazemos O dióxido de cloro
não podemos ingerir nada que tenha
vitamina C naquele espaço de tempo de 8
horas
de novo eu não acho que isso seja
relevante já falei isso eu sei que
dióxido de cloro não é ozônio mas é
muito parecido também o mecanismo tá eu
não acho que isso seja muito relevante
quer ser super preciosista Então faz
isso fica aí o algumas horas sem gerer a
vitamina C Eu não acho isso relevante
[Música]
eh não sei a outra que você não sei qual
que é a outra pergunta da Inara não eh
só se de evitar a cirurgia eu respondi
essa aqui Eu já respondi
tá
Ah tem como não usar tintura química
para cabelos brancos sim tem um vídeo no
meu canal sobre isso procurar lá al tem
mais de um vídeo sobre isso sobre
tinturas naturais de cabelo
ah se consumir os alimentos com grandes
quantidades de nutrientes que competem
com ferro longe dos alimentos ricos em
ferro
consigo evitar
deficiência
Eliseu isso não é relevante também
não se você tá consumindo alimentos que
tenha ferro geralmente eles vão ter
também outros alimentos junto que vão
ter zinco que vão competir um pouco ou
cobre só que isso aqui é um problema só
para quem tá com deficiência de Ferro
aqui não tá no dia a dia não vai fazer
diferença FZ em forma de banana indica
que a quantidade de ferritina eem ferro
estão boas não tem a ver com a
inflamação intestinal tem nada a ver com
pode ter a ver mas não é o principal
Ferritina e ferro
tá ferro na forma de sulfato ferroso é o
ferro na forma de suplemento tem vários
suplementos diferentes não é sulfato
ferroso só não tem vários outros
tipos eh tem como não usar titura
química Já
respondi às vezes eu vejo suplemento
contendo cbd e cúrcuma
cbd e cúrcuma você tá falando de
canabidiol o que que é cbd canabidiol
com cúrcuma
não sei se eu entendi isso aqui
considerando que também não contém altas
concentrações de cumin será que esse
suento vale a pena primeiro que eu não
sei que cbd tá falando porque eu nunca
vi canab diol com cúrcuma é isso tá
falando Não nunca vi esse suplemento
Eliseu que tem a só se for um canabidiol
eles inventaram de p cuma lá no dentro
para tentar
diferenciar mas nunca visto
não eu acho que eles inventaram isso
para chamar atenção eu não usaria isso
não tá
Tá mas eu primeiro que canabidiol não dá
para e tudo bem Tem alguns países que
vendem como suplemento Tá mas no Brasil
e vários outros países do mundo
canabidiol não é suplemento tá é um
medicamento altamente regulado Então
você tá vendendo como suplemento já deve
ser fraco canab diol é medicamento é
contado como medicamento não como
suplemento eu acho que essa Associação
aí
é é meio sem sentido sinceramente tá tá
querendo chamar a atenção de público
Lego olha aqui ó vamos pro artigo né
gente chega de pergunta vamos
lá deixa eu abrir
aqui muito bem
bem Tem um artigo interessante que é de
suma importância paraa saúde cerebral
que é o consumo de carne vermelha
processada eu falei desse assunto eu
acho que não né se eu falei vocês me
avisam tá eo seu impacto no risco de
desenvolver demência tem um estudo novo
que foi apresentado na conferência
internacional de associação de Alzheimer
em 2024 que revelou que consumir
regularmente produtos como bacon
salsicha cachorro quente poderia
aumentar significativamente as chances
de desenvolver demência Então vamos
entender melhor essa pesquisa e como é
que
pode a gente fazer para evitar esses
problemas para proteger o nosso cérebro
Então esse estudo A recente trouxe à
tona uma preocupação muito alarmante que
é o consumo frequente de carne
processada que é o caso de bacon
salsicha embutidos né como isso poderia
aumentar o risco de demência em até 15%
então foi uma pesquisa conduzida por
dados com
dados grandes estudos de acompanhamento
como me o caso nurse Health study e o
Health professionals followup study Esse
estudo analisou a ingestão de área de
carnes processadas e seus efeitos na
saúde cognitiva ao longo de várias
décadas os participantes que consumiram
0,25 ou mais porções de carne processada
por dia tinha um risco
significativamente maior de desenvolver
a demência em comparação com aqueles que
consumiam menos de 0,10 porções
diárias então esses números são
alarmantes Especialmente quando
consideramos o impacto de hábitos
alimentares na nossa saúde mental a
longo
prazo mas Nem tudo são mais notícias
então o estudo também sugeriu que
substituir a carne vermelha processada
por alimentos mais saudáveis como é o
caso de noses e
leguminosas poderia
reduzir desculpa significativamente esse
risco então de acordo com a pesquisa
essa troca poderia diminuir o risco de
demência em números impressionantes
23% então além de reduzir o risco de
demência essa
substituição também foi associada a uma
menor aceleração do envelhecimento
cognitivo o que significa signica que
nosso cérebro poderia permanecer mais
jovem com mais tempo então portanto
pequenas mudanças na dieta como
adicionar mais noses e leguminosas
Lembrando que leguminosas é feijões
favas
lentilhas grão de
bico e também as oleaginosas que são
noses e castanhas
né isso para substituir as carnes
processadas pode ter um Impacto Profundo
na saúde
cerebral então é importante mencionar
que apesar descobertas significativas a
pesquisa sobre a relação entre consumo
de carne vermelha e saúde cognitiva
ainda é
inconsistente certo porque eu t falando
aqui de carne vermelha processada eu
sinceramente eu não acredito que carne
vermelha natural tenha problema mas
muita gente aind acredita que carne
vermelha não
processada ainda é um grande problema
então isso ainda não é totalmente
definido tanto que eu oriento os
pacientes que fazem o protocolo recod
que eu acompanho para comer carne
vermelha no máximo duas vezes semana por
questão de
precaução Apesar de que eu não acredito
que a carne vermelha seja esse bandido
Então muitos estudos anteriores
apresentaram resultados variados sobre a
carne vermelha Então esse estudo em
particular falando da Carne
processada levanta novas questões sobre
o papel específico das carnes novamente
processadas e sua Associação com o
declínio
cognitivo a maioria dos estudos
anteriores ficavam fazendo confusão
misturando carne natural com carne
processada isso gerou muito problema
estatístico os pesquisadores enfatizam
ou enfatizaram que embora a associação
entre carne processada e demência seja
Evidente obviamente eles sempre falam
isso mais estudos são necessários para
entender os mecanismos biológicos por
trás dessa relação então fatores como
idade etnia localização geográfica
também pode influenciar obviamente os
resultados isso torna essencial a
continuidade das pesquisas para obter
conclusões mais definitivas Então as
descobertas desse estudo são importantes
para nos fazer refletir sobre escolhas
alimentares então alimento processado
fique fora seja carboidrato ou não fique
fora de alimento
processado é muito importante então
reduzir o consumo de Carnes processadas
linguiça salsicha embutidos né que mais
salaminho né
Eh
mortadela optar por alternativas mais
saudáveis como Eu mencionei né
oleaginosas e
leguminosas isso pode ser uma estratégia
eficaz para proteger nosso cérebro e
garantir uma vida mentalmente ativa por
mais tempo
certo bem Falta 10 minutos
para a gente poder encerrar aqui a Live
acho que dá tempo de fazer falar mais um
artigo aqui
eh próximo artigo é o impacto do consumo
excessivo de café na nossa saúde
cognitiva Será que beber mais de três
xícaras de café por dia poderia acelerar
o declínio cognitivo então um estudo
recente foi apresentado na conferência
também internacional de associação de
alheimer essa mesma que eu falei do
estudo anterior desse ano de 2024 traz
novos insite sobre essa questão Então
vamos entender melhor o tem a dizer
sobre o café nesse consumo
mais volumoso né porque eu já falei em
ocasiões anteriores que o café protege
contra osheim se você beber com
moderação Então vamos falar aqui de
consumo intenso de café ou
excessivo Todos nós sabemos que o café é
amplamente consumido no mundo inteiro no
Brasil especialmente as pessoas são
muito fãs do café Eu também sou Minha
esposa também é os efeitos da saúde do
Café São polêmicos T sido amplamente
estudados e
debatidos embora algumas pesquisas
anteriores que como eu falei agora a
pouco tenham sugerido que o café pode
ter efeitos benéficos na prevenção de
doenças como Alzheimer o novo estudo que
nós vamos abordar agora revela um outro
lado Outra Face da moeda a pesquisa
analisou o impacto do consumo de café na
inteligência fluida que é uma medida de
funções cognitivas que incluem
raciocínio
abstrato reconhecimento de padrões e
pensamento lógico Então os resultados
mostraram que pessoas que bebem mais de
quatro xícaras mais de quatro xícaras de
café por dia apresentam um declínio mais
acelerado na inteligência fluida ao
longo do tempo então em contraste
aqueles que consomem café maneira mais
moderada né entre uma a três xícaras
diárias parece ter uma proteção então
quer dizer um pouquinho protege demais
atrapalha
né então o estudo também abordou chá o
impacto do consumo de chá na cognição
então de forma curiosa o padrão
observado com chá foi diferente aqueles
que nunca bebiam o chá aí eu tô
relatando aqui que a planta chá tá não é
o chá no sentido de infusão mas no
sentido de ser o chá a planta chá Ok
Camel censes aqueles que nunca bebiam
chá apresentar um declínio maior na
inteligência fluida em comparação com os
consumidores moderados e Altos de chá
então isso sugere que essa planta
Camélia cense assim como café em
quantidade moderada pode ter um efeito
protetor Então os pesquisadores destacam
que apesar dos resultados promissores
ainda são necessários mais estudos
sempre falam a mesma coisa né você D
enjoado de escutar eu falando isso
especialmente com ensaios clínicos
randomizados para entender melhor os
mecanismos neuroprotetores Ok tanto do
café quanto do chá né as catequinas né
até o bromina cafeína
etc Então esse estudo nos lembra da
importância da moderação do equilíbrio
né consumir café demais vai ser um
problema o chá aparentemente não é um
problema mesmo se você consumir muito
então café moderado e chá vão ser
benéficos paraa Saúde cognitiva ex pode
ser prejudicial especialmente do
café
[Música]
eh Então é isso pessoal já estamos com
53 minutos de
Live será que dá tempo para mais um
artigo Acho que dá sim
Então vamos falar de um outro artigo uma
notícia que traz esperança para muitas
pessoas ao redor do mundo quase 50% dos
casos de demência podem ser prevenidos
ou adiados ao longo da vida simplesmente
abordando 14 fatores de risco
modificáveis então o dale braden no
protocolo recode Coloca aí por volta de
30 fatores de risco 36 para ser mais
preciso mas nessa pesquisa de hoje nós
vamos falar de 14 fatores de risco
Então essas novas descobertas foram
apresentadas no último relatório da
comissão lanet sobre prevenção
intervenção e cuidados com a
demência então o relatório da comissão
lanet que foi apresentado nessa mesma
conferência que eu acabei de falar sobre
alheimer desse ano revelou que a
eliminação de 14 fatores de risco ao
longo da vida poderia evitar ou atrasar
quase Metade dos casos de demência de
maneira Global então entre esses fatores
tem dois novos que foram sentados à
lista Aí eu vou colocar do jeito que tá
no artigo pessoal posso não concordar
mas é o que tá no artigo colesterol alto
e a perda de visão então esses se somam
aos outros 12 fatores identificados em
relatórios anteriores como perda
auditiva hipertensão obesidade depressão
e
sedentarismo é basicamente que eu falo
em todos os vídeos né e bons hábitos de
vida evitar as doenças crônicas
você vai evitar o d cognitivo né
hipertensão arterial tá relacionado
intimamente com inst insulínica
obesidade também depressão tá muito
relacionado à experiência da vida e
também a alimentos inflamatórios e o
sedentarismo que eu sem falo então esses
fatores são responsáveis por uma grande
parcela dos casos de demência
especialmente em populações mais
vulneráveis por exemplo o colesterol
elevado aí eu colocaria uma outra
leitura colocaria o desequilíbrio das
gorduras do
sangue no meu entendimento não
colesterol Assim fica muito vago né
elevado então a dislipidemia está
relacionado a 7% dos casos de demência
enquanto que a perda divisão não tratada
poderia contribuir para outros 2% então
essas descobertas reforçam a importância
de um estilo de vida saudável de
cuidados preventivos em todas as fases
da vida
Então esse relatório não apenas
identifica os fatores de risco mas
também fornece recomendações Claras para
indivíduos e governos sobre Como
proteger a saúde cerebral entre as
principais sugestões estão a prevenção e
o tratamento da peda auditiva e visual
então é importante né isso eu já tinha
falado em vídeos anteriores cuidar da
saúde auditiva porque quando você perde
audição a cognição cai junto a
perda de visão era uma coisa que eu não
tinha visto ainda esse artigo me chamou
atenção para
isso também o controle dos fatores de
risco das doenças crônicas né
especialmente as vasculares como é o
caso né da arterosclerose
relacionada à Z epidemia a hipertensão
arterial a resistência insulínica com
pré-diabetes também é importante a
prática de atividades cognitivas ao
longo da vida fazer o seu cé trabalhar
até mesmo depois da aposentadoria e a
promoção de ambientes
sociais que evitem o isolamento né por
isso que as zonas azuis do mundo isso é
um fator crucial que as zonas azuis t
esse senso forte de comunidade que hoje
se perdeu nas grandes cidades até mesmo
na maioria das cidades do interior a
importância da Equidade em Saúde também
foi destacada nesse estudo uma vez que
os fatores de risco para a demência
afetam de maneira de maneira
desproporcional grupos socioeconômicos
favorecidos né os mais pobres e pessoas
que têm menos renda
né Isso significa que a prevenção da
demência deve ser uma prioridade Global
garantindo que todas as pessoas possam
ter acesso aos recursos necessários para
proteger a sua saúde cerebral
certo então é importante mudança de
estilo de vida né cuidar da saúde
cardiovascular se manter ativo
fisicamente ativo intelectualmente ativo
socialmente tudo isso vai ajudar a
evitar doença vai ter um grande impacto
na prevenção da
demência certo
pessoal então a medicina Ortodoxa aos
pouquinhos está aceitando o que nós já
falamos há
anos baseado aí na medicina
funcional Acabou com meu café e pizza de
calabresa vou tomar chá de erra Ira e
capinha limão e pizza de ab não pode
comer sua pizza de vez em quando Estela
mas não Coma todo dia não por favor nem
todo final de semana tá Estela você que
é esportista vou te dar uma colher de
chá você pode comer a sua pizza duas
vezes por mês tá dois sábados ou dois
domingos por mês tá negociado Aí Stela
porque você é maratonista você tem aí
uma colher de chá ok pessoal Muito
obrigado
pela participação de vocês el Depois
você me manda no grupo esse link aí
desse Car dioc que tem cúrcuma que eu
sinceramente eu não conheço deve ser uma
coisa minha boca aí mas eu quero dar uma
olhada tá bom abraço a todos Até a
próxima semana ah essa semana vai ter
Live quinta-feira Tá eu vou fazer uma
mini Live eu vou fazer 20 minutos de
Exposição e 10 só de
perguntas a serem respondidas então terá
uma live de meia hora quinta-feira sobre
o Monkey pox Até lá então se vocês
participarem dessa Live de quinta-feira
Eu sugiro que participem vai ser às 7:30
da noite nós nos vemos lá também até a
próxima